hey youtubers it's Charlie this is gonna
be my Game of Thrones episode 9 Q&A just
careful for spoilers if you haven't seen
the episode yet there was an
overwhelming number of questions about a
couple of the leaps and logic in a
couple of the questionable decisions the
characters made so I'll just start off
with those just because there was so
many people asking a couple of the same
questions so first question why didn't
Sansa tell John about Littlefinger's
army and I think there are two likely
scenarios assuming that sauce is a good
person she likes Jon Snow but she
doesn't trust him to do the right thing
so she's worried that if she tells Jon
then Jon will do something that will
make them lose the battle like he'll act
out of passion which he ended up doing
anyway which is another part of the the
second part of this answer like the
second answer to this question is is the
show wanted to get to a certain point
like it knew the target it wanted to hit
it wanted to have Jon Snow running
around the battlefield covered in mud
this crazy fight between him and Ramsay
so it wasn't as concerned with being
absolutely faithful to real life or all
the logical moments as it was with
getting to this really awesome payoff
moment where a Gandalf rides in with his
surprise army to Helm's Deep I think
it's a combination of those two things
like you get the idea from the teaser
for the next episode that Sansa doesn't
fully trust Jon Snow even though she
loves him but she's been so victimized
by what's happened with Ramsay that she
just can't trust anyone so that leads
her to make questionable decisions and
to the show wanted to get to a couple
really awesome payoff moments and it
wasn't quite as concerned with logic as
it was with getting to those big moments
and the other big general question that
everyone had I already kind of just
answered this in my sanso question but
what's up with all the plot holes with
characters doing questionable things
wouldn't have been easier for Ramsay to
shoot Jon Snow rather than the giant
well that's also the show wanted to get
two big payoff moments like it wanted to
have that moment with Jon so just
beating him into the ground with his
fists so it wasn't quite as worried with
ramsay doing the perfectly logical thing
of just trying to shoot Jon Snow so we
think that largely answers a lot of the
questionable decisions the characters
made in the episode but there were a
couple other funny questions like that
so I made sure to include at least one
Daenerys one in the QA so here we go
next question Ryan asks why did Rickon
not run in a zigzag pattern run
serpentine yeah everybody was shouting
this on Twitter it's because the
showrunner said that there was no way
that riggan was going to survive so they
probably felt like that was the best
for him to go they wanted a really
cinematic looking death and that Dana
Dave explained after the episode that
there was no way Ramsey was going to let
Rick and live so there was no version of
the events in this episode where Rick
and walked away so if you're gonna kill
him off you might as well do it in like
some fun with but it was funny that he
ran in the very Prometheus type way like
we're you know giant Tower is running
down so what do you do you just run in a
straight line so you get to that death
even if it's not completely logical next
question Jedi Master Cheryl asks what do
you think will happen with the remaining
numbers and Karstarks now that the
Starks are back in control of Winterfell
well they'll probably fall in line or
somebody else will take over their
territory seems like that's what happens
with Harrenhal like it gets given to
other people so the car hold if there
aren't other car Starks that fall on
line they'll just give the car whole to
someone else so North is one of those
places that's rich in land but very poor
in population just because it's so hard
to go crops up there so the population
isn't quite as big as say like in the
reach but there is a lot of land to go
around
next question glory asks why is one
dragon bigger than the others well
dragons in captivity tyrion has said
this the show hasn't you know really
fully explained dragon lore but dragons
in captivity never grow as large as they
naturally would if they were able to
roam free so drove on has been roaming
free this whole time he's been eating as
much as he wants he's the apex predator
right now so he just eats whenever he
feels like it
so there's been nothing to hinder his
growth but the other dragons have only
been fed piecemeal like they feed him
every once in a while they've been kept
under the pyramid chained up so animals
in captivity never thrive so now that
they're out they'll start growing a
little bit faster Stan and Dave
explained out to the episode that at
this point as we're seeing him here
they're not quite fully grown so drogon
himself will also get a little bit
larger even though he's already really
big next question Jojo asks can Danny
and Yara just hook up that'd be cool
well they haven't really explained it on
the show but in the books Danny is kind
of pansexual she's just you don't have
sex with women every once in a while
people like Irie that the TV show has
cut out they've presented TV show
Daenerys as being a little more
heterosexual thus far but have been in
the books she does have sex with women
so she and Yara are both kind of up for
anything as Yara said on the TV show
that's actually book accurate I know a
lot of people were like oh Yara is a
lesbian because she's having sex with a
woman
no she just pansexual like Oberyn
Martell
Oberyn Martell does not discriminate who
he has sex with he has sex with men he
has sex with women but that doesn't mean
that he's gay or straight
he Yara Daenerys they're all kind of
like sexual omnivores next question
Priscilla asks do you think that sauce
is pregnant if so what do you think
would happen well first I'll say no I
don't think she's pregnant I think that
what Ramsay said was a metaphor and if
she were pregnant they have moon t4
stuff like that moon tea is kind of like
the Westerosi equivalent of the
morning-after pill so Cersei for
instance she talks about the baby she
lost with Robert there was like one baby
that ended up dying all the other times
that she had sex with Robert the morning
after she would drink moon tea so
jumping through a couple logic hoops I
wouldn't be surprised if Sansa tried to
do the same thing whenever she was with
Ramsay during season five but when
Ramsay was talking about a piece of him
being inside her he was talking more
about the seed of evil not the actual
seed of his genetic material so instead
of a baby growing inside Sansa evil is
growing inside Sansa that's how he was
trying to get inside her head he was
just trying to mess with her next
question nameless asks will all the
other houses of the North kneel to Jon
Snow now well I think the all kneel to
Winterfell
you know questionable as to whether or
not that's going to be Jon Snow leading
all those people the real order of the
day now is in uniting everyone now that
the conflict is over because we have to
get ready for the war for the dawn
there's still a lot of things that have
to happen before we get to that but I
think now that this is over the north
will start rebuilding and I think
Littlefinger part of his plot will be
involved with it you know it's
strengthening the bond between the Vale
and Winterfell I think even if people
don't specifically start following Jon
Snow like thinking of him as a leader
they'll at least start following the
lead of the Starks but I think by rights
Sansa will inherit Winterfell so
technically she'd be in charge but she
seems like she would defer to Jon Snow
on certain decisions so I think it's
gonna be both Sansa and Jon Snow kind of
looking to each other to make decisions
about things in the near term next
question zucchini asks am I the only one
that didn't like the way Emilia Clarke
delivered the line dracarys
so this was one of those are the funny
questions about the show you know not
quite pulling off the thing it was going
for you have to remember that this was
all green screen so I think they wanted
to have like this you know powerful
moment for Daenerys even though it came
across as kind of comical it's the same
thing with this Sansa smirk right here
it
wanted to give her this smirking moment
like ha look at what I've done to you
Ramsey I had this surprise army but in
order to get there it through logic
under the bus this whole conflict that
should have arguably been going on for
an entire season was wrapped up in a
single day so it just like the show
jumping over a couple logical moments so
it winds up being kind of funny when
it's meant to be this really powerful
moment so this is kind of like Game of
Thrones going full of Michael Bay
transformers like a moment that isn't
fully earned but you kind of understand
what they're going for so you can
forgive it you cannot forgive it it's
totally understandable if you want to be
upset with the show about stuff like
this
next question Maureen asks I wonder if
there'll be a moment in the north where
the dispute will suddenly become moot
because there's word of White Walkers
breaching the wall so yeah I definitely
think there'll be a moment where
everyone will just like turn and look up
the north and be like oh my god what is
this army of the dead they've had a
couple moments where like Jon Snow tries
to tell Leon a Mormon about the night
king I think it was actually Davos that
mentioned the night king when they were
trying to get her to help them out but
the north are very practical people so I
think until they see something they're
not going to totally believe it next
question Rakesh asks will the night King
follow brands south of the wall you know
being able to defeat it's magic because
of the mark he left on him so yeah a lot
of people were wondering if the mark
that brain has on him is like the key to
them getting south of the wall because
the show has played it fast and loose
with logic I think there'll be some
other stuff in Vault like some big oh
[ __ ] magic involved where they bring
stuff crashing down so the local
government actually asked the Game of
Thrones people to leave it up as long as
possible the tourism is a big source of
local revenue so yeah would be cool if
like the entire wall went down but the
wall is so massive the DES would just be
very impractical for the TV show so I
think only a small part of it will come
crashing down thank you everyone for so
many questions these are always a ton of
fun to do there'll be at least one more
bonus video before my finale video on
Sunday there'll be a whole bunch of
stuff happening next week after the
finale - they've already started talking
about season seven confirming certain
details so I'll talk about that after I
do like my season 7 predictions video
but be sure to subscribe to get
everything and actually congratulations
to this week's giveaway winner it's
drafty you win a $20 Amazon gift card
just be sure to private message me on
the back end of my channel so I get your
contact details that's just on the about
page there's been a rumor that wins a
winner isn't going to be out till
January the next year but
but I haven't seen any concrete evidence
of that so I'll keep people updated on
the book as we do videos next week but
if there are any bonus videos that you
guys want me to do in the off season
especially after the finale just let me
know in the comments while you guys wait
for my next video to post you can click
here for my finale trailer and you can
click here for my episode 9 video thank
you so much for watching everybody let's
high five I'll see you guys tonight
you